you and uh
primo give me the roots of your guys's
relationship because obviously
you being from la primos you know
originally from texas but we
associate them with new york um talk
about y'all's relationship
and and and you know where it started
um i started rapping man back in the day
days you know
uh p rock seal smooth energy
uh ice cube tone log school e d
so i i've been around for a while so
back in my days
record companies was big on promotional
tours yeah i had to go out
you had to go do in-store sign
autographs so
around the time i first got started um
primo in them had first got started with
gangstar came in rest in peace guru
rest in peace i used to see him a lot on
the road
promo tours and one of my first major
concerts
was with gangstar at the celebrity
theater in anaheim
oh no there's a celebrity theater in
phoenix too yeah it was a celebrity
theater in anaheim
and my first major show was
low profile wow
above the law okay cmw
and gangstar so so re
that's like such a gangster ass west
coast lineup and then gangstar
and then gangstar so you know they was
hot with the manifest record
so i used to bump into him and a lot of
my early gigs you know when i started
touring
was with gangstar whether it was texas
or chicago cleveland
always used to bump into primo on them
so we got cool like that
and then me being signed to
sony you know a lot of my deals in
construction i had to go
to new york and deal with the suit the
suit heads so
just called primo up every time you know
primo coming into town
he picked me up from the airport we go
to his crib just hang out like homies
and we've kept that relationship over
the years
you know he used to remix my uh records
when i was over at uh
sony over at epic um so we just kept a
connection you know
primo used to take me around all the
shows the gigs
you know i got introduced to nas early
and buster rhymes and treach and a lot
of them
cats man we used to just chill so um
we've built that rapport over the years
as to
i can hit primo up man any time of day
anytime a day night whatever and it's
it's always a giving you know primo i
need a beat or sometimes i just want him
to listen to [ __ ]
to make sure i'm on the right track
because as a producer
trust his ear god damn right he got that
hearing being a and you know producing
for everybody
from me to jill scott jay-z jay-z
christina biggie you know so he's had
that
he's had that track record where he has
that good ear so
me and primo's been knowing each other
for a long time and i respect that that
friendship relationship
outside of just the music you know
somebody you would cross paths with
at a concert or a show or whatever
that's the best and exactly yes
i i had one conversation with primo and
it was it was the best it was like
when you meet your idols yeah and it
like they don't
they don't [ __ ] up which you know
because sometimes you'll meet somebody
who you grow up
loving and then you you meet them and or
you interview
the [ __ ] just like damn and
you're disappointed but with primo we
just talked hip-hop and porn stars and
all kinds of whites
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's pretty well
that's primo right yeah primo can talk
you around everything every subject
every anything you know and like i said
that's from being as being a diverse
human being that primo is being and a
good [ __ ] he's always been there for
sure